Então, a aula de hoje é
dedicada, em certo sentido,
a amarrar as pontas soltas.
Eu tenho de vocês 29 páginas de
perguntas, em espaço simples,
que vocês fizeram no
exercício direcionado 9.
E eu vou responder a todas
elas detalhadamente.
Na verdade, eu não vou responder a
todos elas detalhadamente.
Vou escolher algumas das que eu acho
que são de interesse geral...
aqueles com as perguntas não
respondidas estão convidados
a passar por aqui durante o expediente.
Portanto, uma forma de pensar
sobre o que fazemos
quando nos deparamos com um
artigo desta turma é pensar
sobre o que fazer quando você se depara
com um edifício pela 1ª vez
– a Torre Eiffel, por exemplo –
e são dadas orientações
sobre como dar sentido a esse edifício.
Uma das coisas que eu tentei
fazer em cada um dos artigos
ou livros que lemos é dar um
sentido à sua forma geral.
Para oferecer uma noção do
que é distintivo nele,
uma noção de como ele está
estruturado internamente
e de como essa estrutura
interna determina
o que nós somos capazes de
fazer com esse artigo,
o que este artigo é capaz de iluminar.
Mas eu tentei, em certos casos,
dar um sentido do bairro
em que esse artigo pode ser encontrado,
como se ao falar da Torre Eiffel
eu mostrasse onde ela está
situada em Paris.
Ou eu poderia tentar dar
uma noção de como
o artigo se refere a outras
abordagens do mesmo tipo,
como a Torre Eiffel se relaciona
com outros edifícios
monumentais icônicos.
A questão da relação entre
os artigos individuais
que lemos para hoje e o plano maior
é algo a ser discutido na
aula de quinta-feira.
Embora eu a use um pouco
hoje, ao comparar
e contrastar as opiniões da
filosofia política.
O que eu mais quero fazer hoje é
analisar alguns detalhes
de alguns argumentos,
artigos e textos que
estivemos considerado pelo caminho
para que pudéssemos olhar
para parte de um edifício e perguntar
como ele está estruturado,
reconhecendo que, ao fazer isso,
muitas outras partes do prédio
não estão sendo vistas.
Ou podemos querer saber
em relação a que tipo de problema o
edifício foi construído?
Aqui estão as plantas da Torre Eiffel.
Então, o objetivo na aula de hoje é,
baseada numa série de questões
propostas por vocês no exercício 9,
analisar alguns detalhes de
alguns argumentos e,
em menor medida,
colocá-los num plano
maior.
Fazendo isso, é importante
para mim reconhecer
que há um grande número de
questões interessantes
que eu não vou nem chegar
perto de responder.
Havia um grande número de
questões muito interessantes
sobre as conexões entre a filosofia
política de Rawls e Nozick,
por exemplo, e a Constituição dos EUA.
Eu não tenho nada a dizer sobre isso.
Houve perguntas feitas sobre a
infância dos diversos autores
que lemos e como isso pode ter
influenciado as opiniões deles.
Eu não tenho muito a dizer sobre isso.
E, talvez, a minha pergunta favorita:
Eu fui perguntada
se eu pudesse tomar um
café no Blue State
com qualquer um dos autores que
lemos este semestre,
quem eu escolheria?
E eu acho que não
escolheria o Robert Nozick
porque ele não ia querer
ir ao Blue State.
Mas, além disso,
é difícil saber como
responder a essa pergunta.
Então o que eu vou fazer hoje
está, basicamente, em 3 partes.
Na 1ª grande parte da aula,
eu vou tratar alguns detalhes
de um item que sobrou de 2 aulas atrás.
Ou seja, falar um pouco sobre Cass
Sunstein e as normas sociais.
E eu vou usar isso como um
seguimento por certos enigmas
que enfrentamos sobre as
heurísticas e a questão
de como se ajusta ao modelo de
duplo processamento.
Mas isso também será o grande
foco da aula de quinta-feira.
Então, por favor, não
fique desapontado
se eu não responder a sua
pergunta nesta seção.
E eu vou encerrar identificando
um conjunto de cursos que pode
interessar a vocês,
caso esta tenha sido a parte da
aula mais interessante.
Depois, eu tenho algumas coisas a dizer
sobre a seção de filosofia
política do curso.
E vou concluir com a seção de
filosofia moral do curso,
indicando os lugares onde ir
se você esteve particularmente tocado
por algumas das leituras feitas.
Então, vamos começar com uma
introdução um tanto detalhada
sobre o que Cass Sunstein
disse no artigo de 1996
que lemos para a aula de
terça-feira passada.
O que Sunstein tenta fazer neste
artigo é identificar
as nossas atitudes com respeito a
certos tipos de comportamentos
na nossa parte, a parte dos
outros com respeito
a certos tipos de decisões na nossa
parte e como a parte de outros
são afetadas pelo que ele chama, a
partir de um grande corpo
de literatura sociológica,
de normas sociais.
As normas sociais são, basicamente, as
atitudes sociais de aprovação
e desaprovação que especificam,
por meio dos tipos de mecanismos
tácitos que os seres humanos,
bem como os primatas sociais, têm
para expressar aprovação
e desaprovação de suas
ações e do outro.
Isto é, as atitudes sociais de
aprovação e desaprovação,
especificando o que deve ser feito e
o que não deve ser feito.
Coisas sutis, como expressões
faciais, abordagens, rejeições,
todos os sinais sociais
a que estamos extraordinariamente
sensíveis na infância,
nos nossos primeiros anos,
no ensino fundamental e
no ensino médio.
E que continuamos a ser sensíveis
ao longo de nossa vida.
O que Sunstein aponta é que
as normas sociais
determinam os significados sociais.
Ou seja, elas determinam as
atitudes e compromissos
de um tipo específico de
sinais de conduta.
Então, ele destaca, se você
puser o cinto de segurança
num país onde o uso do cinto de
segurança não é a norma,
você está expressando uma
crítica implícita
à habilidade de
condução do motorista.
Pôr o cinto de
segurança é um insulto.
Quando eu e minha família alugamos
um carro na Europa Oriental,
de onde é o meu marido, os
carros normalmente vinham,
se você não aluga numa
grande agência,
com uma pequena placa de metal
que você pode encaixar na
fechadura do cinto de segurança,
sem ter o cinto posto, para
"silenciar" o sinal sonoro irritante
e não ter de insultar ninguém.
Considerando que, em países onde o
uso do cinto de segurança
é a norma, onde o seu uso
é, de fato, a lei,
não pôr o cinto de segurança é
uma expressão de desrespeito.
Quando eu era pequena, a minha
família, para a minha vergonha,
separou os restos de vegetais
dos restos de papel
e colocou-os no quintal, numa
pilha de compostagem.
O significado social de uma
pilha de compostagem
na década de 1970 no
subúrbio de Massachusetts
estava fora da normatividade.
Foi uma expressão de que talvez
nós éramos mais socialmente
conscientes que os nossos vizinhos,
que nós éramos melhores
que os nossos vizinhos.
Mas o que quer que fosse,
não estava no padrão.
Agora, nos Estados Unidos,
uma pilha de compostagem,
um saco reciclável
ou a substituição de uma lâmpada
típica por uma de espectro total
simplesmente expressa o
respeito ao meio ambiente,
em vez de uma atitude isolada.
O meu sobrinho húngaro, quando veio
nos visitar neste verão,
usava o que ele pensava ser
uma camiseta muito
estilosa do Iron Maiden,
que em Budapeste era expressão da moda.
No nosso ambiente
suburbano de Connecticut,
as suas ações foram muitas
vezes mal entendidas
como rebeldes por causa
dos sinais sociais
enviados pelas roupas que usava.
Assim, a razão para ler o
artigo Sunstein,
no contexto da nossa discussão
sobre a filosofia política,
foi lembrar a vocês a quantidade
de camadas de complexidade
existentes quando começamos a pensar
em que tipo de estruturas
sociais são legítimas.
Houve, além disso, uma questão
muito peculiar sobre o artigo
Sunstein, suscitada no âmbito da
nossa folha de perguntas,
na qual eu quero comentar um pouco
por meio da transição.
Um dos alunos perguntou se eu
poderia caracterizar
o argumento de Sunstein
sobre a disposição para pagar e a
disposição para conceder.
O que estamos fazendo agora é
analisar uma viga muito específica
de um argumento muito específico.
Neste artigo, você se lembram,
Sunstein introduz uma discussão
sobre o que é conhecido como
o efeito dotação, que é
basicamente a tendência
do ser humano exigir mais por um
objeto de sua propriedade
que eles estariam dispostos a pagar
para adquirir esse objeto.
E o termo para
o quanto alguém está disposto
a vender algo é o DAP
(a disposição para
aceitar o pagamento),
ao passo que o termo para alguém
disposto a pagar por um objeto é o DP
(disposição para pagar).
Acontece que se eu tiver uma
bonita caneca de Yale
e quero vendê-la para você, as nossas
avaliações de valor vão ser,
frequentemente, bem diferentes.
Eu posso muito bem dizer que
eu não vou vender
a minha linda caneca por
menos de US$ 10.
Enquanto você diz:
"eu não compro a sua caneca
velha por mais de US$ 5".
Se alterarmos a situação,
você com a caneca e eu sem, as
respostas se invertem.
Eu não compraria a sua caneca
velha por mais de US$ 5
e você não me venderia ela
por menos de US$ 10.
Há 15 anos, neste artigo,
Sunstein traçou a hipótese
de que o que explica esse efeito
é principalmente algo sobre
as normas sociais.
Parece que, pelo menos até certo ponto,
ele estava errado sobre isso.
Ele estava errado que as normas sociais
explicam totalmente o fenômeno.
Porque a pesquisa feita
no laboratório Laurie Santos,
nesta mesma universidade,
nos últimos 5 anos, parece
sugerir algo parecido
com o efeito dotação... até
mesmo em macacos-prego.
A tendência a valorizar mais o que
é seu em vez do não é,
mesmo quando os objetos são idênticos.
Dito isso, ainda há razão para pensar
que Sunstein está em algo
quando ele argumenta
que a disposição para pagar, a
disposição para permitir a distinção,
em alguns aspectos, é o
rastreamento de algo
sobre o significado social.
Então, ele ressalta que numa
série de estudos realizados
no contexto da economia
comportamental com indivíduos
"OEIRD"
perto da Universidade de Chicago,
pelo menos para os adultos
ocidentais, educados,
industrializados, ricos e democráticos
parece que essa assimetria é
bastante profunda.
Ele descreveu neste estudo
os detalhes do que eu tinha pensado
em passar, mas eu não vou,
em que se vê uma
assimetria bastante radical
na disposição da pessoa, seja para
adquirir um objeto de outrem
seja para se separar de um
objeto de sua posse.
A resposta de Sunstein para
esses tipos de casos
é sugerir que a diferença
aqui tem muito a ver
com as normas e significados sociais.
Portanto, esse estar
disposto a, por exemplo,
aceitar uma determinada
quantia de dinheiro
para permitir a extinção
de uma espécie,
tem um sentido social muito
diferente do que aceitar seja lá
o que você poderia pensar como
estruturalmente similar
ou estar disposto a pagar uma
determinada quantia de dinheiro
para evitar a extinção da espécie.
Se você considerar o estado do mundo
onde a espécie está extinta
ou se você considerar
o estado do mundo onde a
espécie está presente
e o seu trabalho é salvá-la,
para ser a linha de base,
isso acaba afetando a avaliação
das pessoas sobre o tema.
E Sunstein sugere no artigo,
de modo mais geral,
que inúmeras ações nossas,
inúmeras decisões nossas,
são conduzidas, pelo menos em parte,
pelo sentido social interno e externo.
E que, como consequência, um
mecanismo eficiente
para influenciar as ações e decisões
é influenciar os significados sociais
dessas ações e decisões.
De modo que, sugere ele, isso acaba
por ser um papel inevitável
do governo para regular o comportamento
pela afirmação, introdução
ou negação de certos tipos
de significado social.
E nós abordamos a questão deste tipo de
controle indireto não-racional
do comportamento no contexto da
nossa discussão de Platão
sobre a censura.
Agora, esta distinção entre a
disposição para pagar e para conceder,
os detalhes do que estamos
deixando de lado,
pode ser usada para pensar
sobre um dos exemplos
que eu falei em muitas aulas
e que vamos voltar a falar
na quinta-feira.
Ou seja, o fato de que há uma
tendência inegável das pessoas,
nesta turma inclusive,
para responder de forma diferente ao
caso clássico do Trolley,
onde se desvia um trem que está
prestes a atingir 5 para atingir 1,
e os casos do Trolley que envolve
empurrar alguém de uma ponte.
Portanto, enquanto o 1º produziu apenas
15% de respostas dizendo que era
proibido desviar o trem,
o 2º caso, aquele em que
você está convidado
a empurrar o homem gordo da ponte,
matando 1 e salvando 5,
produziu 78% de respostas
de que o ato era proibido.
Na próxima aula vamos falar muito
sobre como conciliar as intuições
sobre casos particulares
com um compromisso mais geral
com os princípios.
Mas o que eu quero fazer agora é,
ao responder a algumas perguntas,
lembrar a vocês 3 maneiras
diferentes que se pode responder
ao que está acontecendo
nesta assimetria.
Alguém poderia dizer,
utilizando o vocabulário que
Sunstein acaba de introduzir,
que o que acontece no
caso do homem gordo
é que se está sendo
solicitado a aceitar um custo.
Aceitar o custo de ter 1
morte a fim de salvar 5.
Ao passo que o que acontece
no caso da alavanca
é que se está sendo
solicitado a pagar um custo
– algo que não fazia parte
do cálculo inicial –
de ter 1 morte para salvar 5.
E nós sabemos, pela teoria geral,
como funciona o primata humano
– e, talvez, até mesmo
não-humano –,
em que o custo para aceitar algo é
sentido como maior para nós
que o custo para pagar.
Por isso, talvez o que esteja
acontecendo nos casos do trem
é que estamos assimilando-os
por meio de um mecanismo de
heurística que muitas vezes usamos,
um tipo familiar de
processo de raciocínio,
que pode ou não estar rastreando os
nossos compromissos morais.
Ou, talvez, como os casos foram
originalmente expostos,
o que estamos rastreando aqui nas
nossas diferentes respostas
é uma distinção real
moralmente profunda
entre a violação de
direitos e utilidade,
onde, em casos que a violação de
direitos entre em jogo,
permitir que 1 morra ou
matar 1 para salvar 5
é moralmente errado.
Enquanto que, em casos em que os
direitos não entram em jogo,
permitir que 1 morra ou
matar 1 para salvar 5
é moralmente aceitável.
Ou, talvez, o que esteja
acontecendo neste caso é,
como sugere Josh Greene, com base no
seu trabalho de neuroimagem,
que num dos casos estamos
respondendo emocionalmente
e, no outro, estamos
respondendo de racionalmente.
O que a 1ª e a 3ª, mas não a
2ª, respostas têm em comum
– ou seja, o que as 2 respostas
que sugerem que devemos tomar
como diferencialmente
informativas as nossas respostas
para o caso do homem gordo e para o
caso da testemunha sugerem –
é que ao refletir sobre esses casos
estamos pensando num deles
com um modo de reflexão
e no outro com um outro
modo de reflexão.
E durante todo o curso fomos
introduzidos ao fato de que
em cada tradição
intelectual há uma sugestão
de que a compreensão humana do mundo
procede de várias maneiras.
O vernáculo científico
contemporâneo disso
utiliza a noção de
duplo processamento.
Isso sugere que há 2 sistemas: O
sistema 1 e o sistema 2.
Se o sistema 1 é
evolutivamente primitivo
e compartilhado com os
animais não-humanos,
o sistema 2 é evolutivamente
recente e compartilhado,
se não com todos os animais,
apenas com aqueles mais próximos de
nós na árvore evolutiva.
O sistema 1 é inconsciente,
ou pré-consciente,
enquanto o sistema 2 é consciente.
O sistema 1 é automático, enquanto
o sistema 2 é controlado.
O sistema 1 é passivo, enquanto
o sistema 2 é ativo.
O sistema 1 é rápido, enquanto
o sistema 2 é lento.
O sistema 1 é associativo,
enquanto o sistema 2 é
baseado em regras.
Agora uma das coisas que
fizemos durante todo o curso
foi analisar várias formas de
chegar à distinção
desta versão particular
sem tentar decidir
qual das estruturas é a mais
útil em todos os contextos.
Em vez disso, reconhecemos que
em certos domínios
pode ser útil, usando os
termos de Platão,
ter o espírito e o apetite
puxando numa direção
e a razão puxando em outra.
Isso pode ser útil em alguns contextos,
com o alief causando certos tipos de
comportamentos não-reflexivos
enquanto a crença causa certos tipos
de comportamentos reflexivos.
Isso pode ser útil em alguns
contextos das heurísticas
nos levando a responder a um tipo de
forma e cognição plena,
ou reflexão, nos levando a
responder a outro.
Mas é importante saber que na hora
de escolher esses 3 modos
particulares que analisamos nesta
distinção abrangente,
esquecemos de olhar
para muitos outros tipos de
modelos de duplo processamento.
Aqui estão 15 ou mais
retirados do artigo de Evans
que lemos em meados de janeiro.
E para os propósitos da nossa
discussão neste curso,
as semelhanças entre
esses pontos de vista
são mais relevantes que as diferenças.
Se, no entanto, vocês estão
intrigados com o conjunto de questões
que eu acabei de passar de forma breve,
há vários lugares para ir em seguida.
A maioria dos cursos oferecidos pelo
programa de ciência cognitiva
analisa os tipos de questões que
eu só estive discutindo.
Como o raciocínio humano é afetado
pelas características
estruturais do cérebro?
Até que ponto podemos
sistematizar os tipos de erros
que os seres humanos parecem
cometer no raciocínio?
Em que medida esses erros – ou o
que chamamos de erros –
não são realmente meios eficazes
para navegar por vários
tipos de ambientes?
Vocês também podem analisar
esses tipos de perguntas
no contexto da psicologia social,
psicologia cognitiva, psicologia
do desenvolvimento... e haverá
inúmeros cursos oferecidos
em psicologia no próximo ano que
vão aprofundar muito mais
sobre as questões citadas por mim.
A School of Management oferece cursos
de economia comportamental
abertos para alunos de graduação que
têm os créditos necessários.
E no contexto do
departamento de Filosofia,
existem cursos históricos
que analisam Platão
com seriedade e profundidade.
Na verdade, há um curso neste semestre
apenas sobre A República de Platão.
Há cursos que analisam Aristóteles
ou a ética de Aristóteles.
Cursos que analisam cada um dos
autores que estivemos considerando.
Então, aos que estão intrigados
com o que acabamos de falar,
eis um mapa do conhecimento.
2º grande conjunto de temas que
eu quero abordar hoje.
Quase 1/3 das perguntas me pedia
– talvez pelo caráter mais
recente do tema –
para discutir novamente a
relação entre Nozick e Rawls
e para dizer como isso, talvez,
se encaixa com Hobbes e a
teoria do contrato social.
Assim que, pegando emprestado do
meu colega Thomas Pogge,
aqui está uma forma útil para pensar
sobre a diferença entre os 3.
Eu vou dar uma visão
geral da diferença
e, em seguida, tentar apresentá-los com
uma explicação sistemática
onde Hobbes, Rawls e Nozick são
parecidos e diferentes.
Todos os 3 trabalham no que é conhecido
como a tradição do contrato social.
Todos os 3 alegam que isso está
num certo tipo de interesse
por parte dos seres humanos ao pactuar
com um determinado tipo de estrutura
social, mesmo que, assim,
abdiquem de um pouco da sua liberdade.
Hobbes destaca que isso é de
utilidade prudencial para nos
envolvermos num contrato social.
Estamos melhor do que estaríamos
se não formássemos parte de um Estado.
Mas o estado de natureza a
que Hobbes recorre
é puramente imaginário.
É um contrato hipotético, cujo
valor para nós é prudencial.
Rawls sugere que é de utilidade
moral nos envolvermos
no tipo de contrato social que o
estado rawlsiano representa.
Nós imaginariamente
frequentamos a posição
original
por trás do véu da ignorância.
E fazendo isso chegamos a
algo moralmente digno.
Nozick, em contraste, se preocupa
com a forma como as coisas
realmente venham a existir.
Mas, como Rawls,
ele está interessado em que tipo de
justificação moral isso fornece.
Assim, enquanto Hobbes enfoca o
que um contrato hipotético
nos diz sobre o que é
prudente para nós,
Rawls enfoca o que um contrato
hipotético nos diz sobre
o que é moral e Nozick enfoca
um determinado conjunto
histórico de eventos
onde isso se destaca no que diz
respeito à moralidade.
Vamos começar analisando o
argumento de Hobbes.
Hobbes nos apresenta, em O Leviatã,
o que ele chama de estado de natureza.
Uma situação imaginária,
o modo de vida se não houvesse
poder comum a temer.
Onde a vida é solitária, pobre,
sórdida, embrutecida e curta.
E sugere que o nosso
objetivo prudencial,
o que é de utilidade para nós,
é escapar do estado de natureza.
Por quê? Porque todos nós temos um
"medo da morte, o desejo
[da] vida confortável
e a esperança de consegui-las
através do trabalho".
Mas para Hobbes, isso dá origem
– pensando sobre o fato
de que estar no estado de
natureza é ruim para nós –
a uma série de conclusões
racionalmente obrigatórias,
das quais examinamos 3.
São o que Hobbes chama de
leis de natureza.
As coisas, as exigências que nos
damos conta pela razão
se temos o objetivo prudencial
da vida confortável.
Em especial, temos de buscar a paz,
se há uma chance de obter a paz
e se não reservar para nós
o direito da guerra.
1ª lei de natureza.
Renunciar os nossos direitos,
na medida em que os outros estão
dispostos a fazer o mesmo.
2ª lei de natureza.
Executar os nossos pactos,
que é manter as nossas promessas,
assumindo que os outros estão
dispostos a fazer o mesmo.
Mas há um problema estrutural nisso.
O problema estrutural é aquele
articulado pelo Dilema do Prisioneiro.
E por causa disso, diz Hobbes, o
único modo que temos de fazer
o que exige a razão – buscar a paz,
renunciar os nossos direitos e
realizar os nossos pactos;
agindo, assim, na 1ª parte
dessas cláusulas –
é se instituirmos um
governo autoritário.
Um poder civil suficiente para
obrigar a não-deserção
no dilema do prisioneiro.
Prestem atenção, então,
nessas 4 etapas principais.
Porque eu vou passar por
elas depois com Rawls
e com Nozick.
Nós estamos interessados
??numa situação,
uma conclusão
racionalmente
compulsória
e um mecanismo
estruturalmente
compulsório.
Como é que isso funciona para
Rawls? Rawls diz...
Vamos considerar a seguinte
situação hipotética.
A posição original, onde nos situamos
atrás do véu de ignorância,
sem saber quem seremos na sociedade,
e escolhemos as estruturas básicas
pelas quais a nossa
sociedade será regida.
O objetivo ao nos
envolvermos nesta atividade
é articular as condições de
uma sociedade justa.
Por quê?
Porque a "justiça é a primeira
virtude das instituições sociais,
como a verdade o é para o pensamento".
O objetivo é articular uma
filosofia política
para chegar àquela que respeite
as nossas normas morais.
Assim como o objetivo de Hobbes é
articular as restrições
que governam uma sociedade
política legítima
para identificar quem respeita as
nossas normas prudenciais.
Portanto, qual é a conclusão
racionalmente compulsória
ao tomar essa situação hipotética
e este objetivo específico?
Rawls afirma... tal como Hobbes pensou,
pensando na estrutura do
estado de natureza,
através da razão, as 3
leis de natureza.
Rawls também pensa assim,
na estrutura da posição original
com o objetivo de desenvolver
uma sociedade moral,
dado os princípios de justiça.
Em especial, o 1º princípio
de liberdade igual:
que em nenhuma circunstância os
direitos fundamentais
de um serão sacrificados pela
utilidade de muitos.
E em 2º lugar, na medida em que
exista desigualdades na sociedade,
elas devem ser ligadas a posições
e órgãos abertos a todos
e de forma que sejam vantajosas
para os menos favorecidos.
Além disso, Rawls não pensa apenas
numa situação hipotética,
no objetivo moral e na conclusão
racionalmente compulsória
que podemos tirar disso, mas
também no tipo de mecanismo,
de estrutura, que a
sociedade precisa ter.
E a sugestão é que ela seja imparcial
e com direitos e deveres básicos.
Liberdade de palavra,
liberdade de expressão,
liberdade de pensamento,
responsabilidades iguais como
contribuição
para a manutenção da
comunidade como um todo.
E por causa de fatos sobre a
eficiência, Rawls está pronto para,
pelo menos provisoriamente,
apoiar, como um mecanismo
eficaz para isso,
uma economia de mercado com alguma
tendência para a redistribuição.
Observem que se trata de um argumento
quase paralelo ao de Hobbes.
Pegamos uma situação hipotética.
Nós temos um objetivo.
Nós racionalizamos o nosso
caminho pela situação
e determinamos certos tipos
de restrições.
E, então, identificamos que tipo de
estrutura social isso nos oferece.
A seguir, vamos ver o que isso nos
oferece no contexto de Nozick.
Nozick está interessado, não
numa situação hipotética,
mas numa situação histórica.
Em particular, ele está
interessado no que devemos fazer
sobre o fato de que uma
distribuição especial de
recursos
ter resultado de uma série de
transferências justas.
Uma série de transferências onde
os bens foram adquiridos
de forma legítima e
transferidos de forma
legítima,
independentemente do que
esse padrão produziu.
Observem que, apesar de termos
lido apenas a discussão
de Nozick sobre a justiça na
propriedade e, consequentemente,
analisado uma questão
bastante estreita sobre
em que condições é legítimo
possuir uma propriedade,
o argumento de Nozick no que diz
respeito às propriedades
pode ser generalizado a
qualquer tipo de decisões
feitas pelas pessoas.
O que legitima as propriedades
na imagem de Nozick
é que elas são o resultado de
um processo legítimo.
E, como consequência, qualquer tipo
de contrato que participamos
no formato que Nozick chama de
livre vai acabar entrando
na mesma categoria histórica.
Portanto, o interesse de
Nozick é na pergunta:
dada as coisas que por uma questão
de contingência histórica
acabam sendo do jeito que são,
em termos da distribuição de bens e da
distribuição dos contratos,
que tipo de força moral isso tem?
O objetivo de Nozick é
determinar se esta distribuição
de propriedades e
compromissos é legítima.
E a sugestão dele é que, desde que
a propriedade seja adquirida
e transferida honestamente, então
qualquer que seja a distribuição
de resultados será uma
distribuição justa.
E vocês se lembram que nós detalhamos
a ideia de Nozick sobre a aquisição
justa, onde ele diz, basicamente,
que um objeto é de posse legítima
se ele foi adquirido de uma forma
em que o valor adicionado
ao objeto não faz com que a
posse deixe os outros pior
do que estariam se você não
tivesse adquirido o objeto.
E em que as transferências
justas são aquelas
que existe envolvimento voluntário.
Uma consequência disso, como vimos no
exemplo "Wilt Chamberlain",
é que mesmo se começarmos
com uma distribuição
perfeitamente uniforme dos bens
entre os indivíduos,
é quase certo que acabaremos
com uma desigualdade.
E observem que o mesmo tipo
de argumento proposto
para a distribuição de bens
pode ser proposto para a
distribuição de obrigações.
Então Nozick está interessado
na situação histórica.
Ele tem um objetivo moral, ou seja,
determinar se a distribuição é justa.
E a conclusão que ele tira disso, ao
pensar sobre essa estrutura,
é que qualquer intervenção nas
distribuições justas
de propriedades ou contratos é
uma violação de direitos.
Afinal de contas,
as únicas coisas importantes para as
propriedades serem justas,
na imagem de Nozick,
é se elas foram adquiridas e
transferidas honestamente.
E o fato de que isso, por uma questão
de problemas de coordenação
do tipo enfrentado no
problema dos comuns,
inevitavelmente resulta em
distribuições desiguais
não é de nenhum interesse para o
tipo de imagem histórica
considerado por Nozick.
Do mesmo modo,
o fato de que, como resultado da
contingência histórica,
eu possa acabar pactuada de uma forma
que esteja subordinada a você
não é injusto para Nozick,
afinal nenhuma intervenção
num processo justo
pode ser realizada sem
violar os direitos.
Portanto, o mecanismo
estruturalmente compulsório
que Nozick defende é o do
Estado mínimo.
Então, qual é a imagem entre os
nossos filósofos políticos?
A ideia é esta:
Hobbes está interessado em
pensar sobre o que um estado
hipotético de natureza, considerado o
ponto de vista da prudência,
nos diz ser racional.
Ele nos diz que certas leis de
natureza são racionais,
cuja execução só é possível
pela introdução de um
Estado autoritário.
Rawls nos pede para pensar
hipoteticamente,
a partir da posição do
véu de ignorância,
o que seria necessário para
termos uma sociedade moral,
conclui que ela seria regida pelos
princípios de justiça
e identifica um mecanismo
que eu tenho chamado de "Suécia".
E Nozick indaga o que podemos fazer,
dado que uma distribuição real
surgiu como resultado
de um bando de transferências justas
e conclui que se o nosso objetivo
é respeitar os direitos,
então o único estado
legítimo é o Estado mínimo.
Bom, nós tivemos cerca de 4 aulas
sobre filosofia política.
Para onde ir se vocês querem mais?
O departamento de Filosofia oferece
cursos de filosofia política,
seja cursos de investigação
ou sobre cada um dos
sujeitos lidos por nós.
You can take a course surveying
political philosophy
from Plato past Nozick.
Ou pode fazer um curso
sobre qualquer um dos
autores individualmente.
O departamento de Ciência
Política, da mesma forma,
oferece cursos
historicamente
estruturados
e cursos sobre os nossos autores.
Quase todos os cursos listados
em Ética, Política e
Economia abordarão
os tipos de perguntas que eu acabei
de mencionar neste quadro.
E no contexto do
departamento de Economia e,
de fato, em 3 ou 4 outros departamentos,
vocês podem pensar sobre a
teoria dos jogos
como uma forma de
representar essas
estruturas,
ou pensar sobre a política, no
contexto de uma estrutura econômica.
Já são 11h19.
Vou integrar a discussão
sobre a moralidade
e as respostas a essas questões na
nossa aula final de quinta.
Mas a minha esperança é de que,
mesmo que eu não responda
todas as 500 perguntas,
a aula de hoje tenha
oferecido algum sentido
sobre como algumas peças se encaixam.
E nós vamos continuar na
quinta-feira...